WELCOME TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON BUSINESS, PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT, ONE OF
SEVERAL COMMITTEES, PERFORMING A
LIGHTNING ROUND THIS MORNING. WE
WILL COME TO ORDER IN 60S.
MEMBERS IN THE BUILDING WHO ARE
PART OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS, PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. WE NEED
YOU FOR A QUORUM. PLEASE MAKE
YOUR WAY TO ROOM 2200. WE'RE IN
2000/200 DIFFERENT ROOM THAN
USUAL. PLEASE HEAD DOWN HERE.
AND IF YOU ARE AN AUTHOR ON OUR
AGENDA TODAY, HOPEFULLY YOU ARE
WITHIN STEPS OF OUR DOOR. 60S.
WE WILL START.
OKAY ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GONNA CALL
THE BUSINESS, PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
MEETING OF WEDNESDAY, AUGUST
28TH TO ORDER. SEE IF WE CAN
KNOCK THIS OUT AGAIN. ONE MORE
REMINDER, SENATORS WHO ARE ON
THE BUSINESS, PROFESSIONS,
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE,
WE NEED YOU IN ROOM 2200. SO
THAT WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
THAT BEING SAID, WE HAVE ONE
BILL ON THE AGENDA TODAY, AND WE
HAVE THE AUTHOR HERE WITH US,
SENATOR LYMAN. WE DON'T HAVE THE
QUORUM. WE'LL CALL IT AS SOON AS
WE DO. BUT GO AHEAD AND PRESENT
YOUR BILL TO US. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR, AND MEMBERS.
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE IS A GROWING
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. A 2020
REPORT CONDUCTED BY THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION REVEALED
THAT PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS SEE
A GROWING ISSUE PRESENTED BY
DEMENTIA AND FEEL UNPREPARED.
THIS BILL ADDS ALZHEIMER'S AND
DEMENTIA TRAINING AS AN OPTION
TO THE EXISTING CONTINUING
EDUCATION REQUIREMENT FOR
PHYSICIANS WHO HAVE A PATIENT
POPULATION, OF WHICH OVER 25%
ARE 65 YEARS OLD OR OLDER AND
APPLIES THE SAME REQUIREMENT TO
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANTS AND NURSE
PRACTITIONERS. SB 639 WILL
ENSURE THAT HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS ARE EQUIPPED FOR
DEMENTIA DETECTION AND DIAGNOSES
STATEWIDE. GREAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YOU HAVE SOME LEAD
WITNESSES WITH YOU. I DO THANK
YOU. GO RIGHT AHEAD. PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES. YOU EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES. GO RIGHT
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
ASHBY. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY. MY NAME IS MELISSA
WASS AND I AM HERE FROM
SACRAMENTO TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT
FOR SB 639 BY SENATOR MONIQUE
LIMON, WHICH ENSURES THAT
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS WHO TREAT
OLDER CALIFORNIANS RECEIVE
DEMENTIA TRAINING. IN 2013, MY
MOTHER WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
ALZHEIMER'S, MAKING THE
BEGINNING OF A LONG JOURNEY OF
HEARTBREAK FOR MY FAMILY. FOR
EIGHT YEARS, MY WIFE AND I CARED
FOR HER AROUND THE CLOCK. WE
WERE HER CAREGIVERS, HER
ADVOCATES, AND HER COMPANIONS.
AS WE WATCHED, THE WOMAN WE
LOVED SLOWLY SLIP AWAY FROM US.
OUR PARTICULARLY HEART WRENCHING
MOMENT OCCURRED ABOUT A WEEK
BEFORE MY MOTHER PASSED. HOSPICE
INFORMED US THAT SHE COULD NO
LONGER SWALLOW, AND WE WERE
FORCED. FACED WITH AN
UNIMAGINABLE DECISION, EITHER
INSERT A FEEDING TUBE OR
PROLONGING HER SUFFERING OR
WITHHOLD FOOD, KNOWING SHE WOULD
SOON PASS. WE CHOSE TO HONOR MY
MOTHER'S DIGNITY BY NOT
INSERTING A FEEDING TUBE, HOPING
TO MAKE HER FINAL DAYS AS
PEACEFUL AS POSSIBLE. BUT WHAT
HAPPENED IN HER LAST MOMENTS WAS
SOMETHING NONE OF US WERE
PREPARED FOR. ON THE MORNING OF
HER DEATH, THE HOSPICE NP TOLD
TOLD US MY MOTHER'S TIME HAD
COME. MY WIFE AND I HELD HER
HAND SAYING OUR FINAL GOODBYES
AFTER SHE WAS PRONOUNCED DEAD,
SOMETHING UNEXPECTED OCCURRED.
MY MOTHER STARTED TO BREATHE
AGAIN. THIS HAPPENED THREE
TIMES, EACH MORE AGONIZING THAN
THE LAST, AND THE NP REFUSED TO
ADMINISTER MORE MORPHINE. THE NP
SEEMED UNPREPARED AND ADMITTED
SHE WAS FREAKED OUT. SHE
REALIZED SHE HAD NEVER SEEN
SOMEONE DIE DIRECTLY FROM
ALZHEIMER'S, AS MY MOTHER HAD NO
OTHER HEALTH ISSUES, MY MOTHER'S
PASSING WAS THE MOST PAINFUL
EXPERIENCE OF MY LIFE, MADE
WORSE BY THE LACK OF SUPPORT AND
EXPERTISE WE NEEDED. THE NP
DIDN'T HAVE THE TRAINING TO
MANAGE THE UNIQUE SYMPTOMS OF
END STAGE ALZHEIMER'S. BECAUSE
OF THAT, MY MOTHER, MY WIFE AND
I ENDURED UNNECESSARY SUFFERING.
THIS IS WHY I'M HERE TODAY
ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
PASSING THE BILL. ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE IS A DEVASTATING ILLNESS
THAT REQUIRES SPECIALIZED
KNOWLEDGE AND COMPASSIONATE
CARE. OUR NPS AND PAS ARE ON THE
FRONT LINES CARING FOR PATIENTS
LIKE MY MOTHER IN NEED.
SPECIALIZED TRAINING I URGE YOU
TO VOTE. VOTE AYE ON SB 639. BY
PASSING THIS BILL, YOU SUPPORT
CONTINUED EDUCATION FOR HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONALS AND ENSURE
FAMILIES LIKE MINE RECEIVE THE
GUIDANCE AND CARE THEY NEED IN
THEIR DARKEST HOURS. YOU ARE
GIVING DIGNITY TO THOSE
SUFFERING FROM ALZHEIMER'S AND
PEACE TO THOSE WHO LOVE THEM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SHARING YOUR STORY AND YOUR
MOM'S STORY WITH US. I'M GOING
TO PAUSE BEFORE WE GO TO THE
SECOND WITNESS AND ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. ASHBY. ASHBY. HERE
NGUYEN. HERE. NGUYEN. HERE.
ARCHULETA. HERE. ARCHULETA HERE.
BECKER. DODD. EGGMAN. EGGMAN.
HERE GLAZER. MENGIBAR. MILO
HERE. MILO. HERE. HENGERVAR.
HERE ROTH. ROTH. HERE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. HERE. WILK. OKAY OKAY.
GO AHEAD. YEAH, I'M ERIC
DOUGHTY. I'M WITH THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION. JUST
PROUD TO SPONSOR THE BILL AND
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU. ARE THERE
OTHERS IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL WHO WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE ME TWO TESTIMONY NOW? IF
SO, PLEASE COME TO THE MIC. GIVE
US YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
SEEING NONE, ARE THERE ANY IN
THE ROOM WHO OPPOSE THE BILL?
SEEING NO ONE WILL COME BACK TO
THE WILL. COME TO THE COUNCIL.
DÍAS HERE. SORRY, WE'RE NOT A
CITY COUNCIL. WE'RE COMING BACK
TO THE SENATE. DÍAS, SENATOR
EGGMAN AND THEN SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU. SENATOR,
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. AND I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
SHARING YOUR PAIN AND YOUR STORY
AND THE COURAGE TO MAKE OTHER
PEOPLE'S PASSING BETTER. I'D
MOVE THE BILL. GREAT GO AHEAD,
SENATOR ARCHULETA. YEAH. THANK
YOU. AND, MY CONDOLENCES TO YOUR
FAMILY, YOURSELF AND YOUR WIFE
AND IT'S A DEEPLY, DEEPLY SAD
STORY, BUT, WELL RECEIVED.
THAT'S SO IMPORTANT. AND,
SENATOR, I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD, BECAUSE,
AS WE ALL KNOW, OUR POPULATION
IS GETTING OLDER IN THE INNER
CITIES AS WELL AS MÀ
COMMUNITIES. THEY ARE STRONGER,
LONGER, AND WE NEED THE
EXPERTISE. AND I APPRECIATE THE
BILL. AND I WILL BE SUPPORTING
IT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER COLLEAGUES WISHING TO
SPEAK, SENATOR NILO? THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR, I DIDN'T HEAR THE
TESTIMONY, BUT I HAVE MET WITH,
MEMBERS OF THE ALZHEIMER'S
ORGANIZATION, AND I CERTAINLY.
WELL, I DON'T REALLY HAVE
NECESSARILY SYMPATHY WITH THE
ISSUE. I HAVE EMPATHY BECAUSE
I'M YOUR TARGET AUDIENCE IN A
SENSE. BY BY VIRTUE OF AGE. BUT
MY CONCERN IS THAT ALL,
PRACTITIONERS IN THE MEDICAL
MEDICAL COMMUNITY HAVE
SHORTAGES. I DON'T THINK THAT,
CARE FOR, FOR ELDERS IS UNIQUE
THAT WAY. AND, SO MY CONCERN IS
THAT JUST LIKE WE'RE SEEING
MULTIPLE, PROVISIONS FOR THE,
ADVANTAGE FOR A LICENSURE OF
PEOPLE IN CERTAIN GROUPS, I'M
CONCERNED THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE THAT IN THIS AREA, TOO,
WHERE THERE IS A SHORTAGE OF
MEDICAL PRACTITIONERS IN OTHER
MEDICAL DISCIPLINES THAT WOULD
DO THE SAME THING, REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL EDUCATION, TO THE
POINT WHERE WE BEGIN TO
PRESCRIBE WHAT THE CONTINUING
EDUCATION SHOULD BE FOR
PRACTITIONERS. AS OPPOSED TO THE
PROFESSION DECIDING WHAT THEY
NEEDED. NUMBER ONE, AND I GUESS
A QUESTION WELL, A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS IS, HOW SENATOR, I'M
JUST GOING TO ASK YOU TO BE AS
SUCCINCT AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE WE
HAVE MULTIPLE MEMBERS WHO HAVE
AT LEAST 2 OR 3 OTHER COMMITTEES
TO GET TO. I KNOW, AND I DO TOO,
BUT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE.
IT SURE IS, AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT. I DIDN'T WANT TO HAVE TO
ASK ALL THESE QUESTIONS EXACTLY.
FOR THAT REASON. I'VE GOT FOUR
COMMITTEE MEETINGS TODAY, SO,
BUT MY QUESTION IS, HOW WILL WE
KNOW WHAT THE CONCENTRATION IS
IN ANY PARTICULAR PRACTICE AND
THEREFORE HOW TO REQUIRE THE 20%
EDUCATION? AND SECONDLY, WHAT'S
THE POSITION OF THE MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION ON THIS? THEY APPEAR
TO BE NEUTRAL I GUESS. RIGHT. SO
I THINK ON MOST SO I'VE BEEN
RUNNING BILLS ON ALZHEIMER'S AND
DEMENTIAS FOR EIGHT YEARS. SO
JUST TO BE CLEAR, I RUN A BILL
IN THIS SPACE FOR EIGHT YEARS.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'VE
LEARNED WHEN IT COMES TO
TRAINING IS THAT NEUTRAL IS
ACTUALLY A GOOD PLACE TO BE, IN
PARTICULAR, BECAUSE I THINK THAT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE PHYSICIANS,
THEY'RE LOOKING AT, YOU KNOW,
EVERYONE'S PRACTICE IS
DIFFERENT. SO I, YOU KNOW, WE'VE
BEEN WORKING FOR TWO YEARS ON
THIS PARTICULAR BILL. THAT'S WHY
IT HAS A LOWER NUMBER. THIS BILL
HAS BEEN IN PROGRESS. AND SO
WHAT WE HAVE IS, THE ABILITY TO,
YOU KNOW, DO TO HAVE THIS
TRAINING. I THINK THAT YOU WILL
SEE IN MANY PROFESSIONS THAT WE
OFFER DIFFERENT SUBJECT MATTER
TRAININGS FOR LICENSURE, AND
THAT IS VERY COMMON. SO THIS
BILL DOESN'T DO ANYTHING
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE DO FOR
OTHER PROFESSIONS. AND I THINK
THAT AS WE SEE, THERE IS A
GENERAL CONSENSUS THAT THIS IS A
GROWING ISSUE. SO THAT'S NOT
ACTUALLY WHAT'S THE DEBATE.
RIGHT. THE DEBATE IS ABOUT THE
TRAINING PROGRAM AND WHETHER OR
NOT IT MAKES SENSE. AND HOW, YOU
KNOW, YOUR QUESTION ABOUT HOW
WILL WE KNOW THE YOU KNOW, THE
PRACTITIONERS, THEY KNOW WHO
THEIR POPULATION IS. AND SO THIS
IS, YOU KNOW, A QUESTION THAT
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO ANSWER.
I DON'T KNOW, I CAN'T TELL YOU
WHO SEES WHO, BUT THEY CAN.
THANK YOU. SENATOR, ARE YOU
GOOD? OKAY SENATOR ROTH. WELL, I
JUST WANT TO SAY, YOU KNOW,
UNFORTUNATELY, WE HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS ALL AROUND THE
ISSUE, AND WE PARTICULARLY HAVE
A SHORTAGE OF SPECIALISTS IN
SOME OF THESE AREAS, WHETHER
IT'S BEHAVIORAL HEALTH OR THIS
ONE. AND OUR OUR INTERNAL
MEDICINE FOLKS AND OUR FAMILY
PRACTITIONERS AND THE NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AND PA'S WHO SEE
PATIENTS IN AREAS WHERE
SPECIALISTS DO NOT EXIST, ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO TRAIN UP TO
HELP US DEAL WITH THE HEALTH
CRISIS THAT WE'RE IN. AND THIS
IS ONE EXAMPLE THAT YOU ARE
ADDRESSING WITH THIS BILL. THERE
ARE OTHERS IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
THERE ARE PROBABLY OTHERS IN
SOME OF THE OTHER SPECIALTIES,
AS WELL. AND THE FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND THE INTERNISTS
THAT I'VE SPOKEN TO WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISPLAY THEIR
SKILLS IN THESE AREAS IN THE IN
THE MORE SPECIALIZED AREAS. AND
SO I COMMEND YOU FOR THE BILL,
AND I AM GOING TO BE AN EYE.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. I THINK
I'M GOING TO CLOSE US OUT HERE
AND THEN GIVE THE SENATOR A
CHANCE TO MAKE HER CLOSING
STATEMENT, I STILL HAVE TO
STEADY MYSELF AS AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL WHEN THIS COMES UP,
BECAUSE, I TOOK THAT SAME
JOURNEY AS YOU WITH MY DAD, AND
IT'S VERY, ON THE SURFACE FOR
ME, TOO. AND I DON'T THINK THAT,
WE CAN IN ANY WAY MAKE THE
SITUATION WORSE BY MAKING SURE
THAT HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS
HAVE MORE TRAINING FOR THE
SPECIFIC NEEDS OF ALZHEIMER'S
AND DEMENTIA, IT'S A HORRIBLE
DISEASE TO WATCH A LOVED ONE
EXIT THIS WORLD WITH. I'VE BEEN
THERE EXACTLY WHERE YOU WERE FOR
THAT FINAL BREATH. I KNOW
EXACTLY HOW YOUR HEART FEELS.
THERE'S NO DOUBT IN MY MIND THAT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS QUITE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE A CHAMPION
LIKE SENATOR LIMÓN, WHO TAKES
THIS UP EVERY YEAR. I QUITE
FRANKLY, COULDN'T DO IT BECAUSE
I'D BE ALREADY IN TEARS. SO I'M
GOING TO STOP TALKING NOW. LET
HER CLOSE. BUT YOU CERTAINLY
HAVE MY SUPPORT. AND, AND MY, MY
KINSHIP IN A CLUB THAT NEITHER
ONE OF US WOULD LIKE TO BE IN.
THANK YOU. AND THANK YOU FOR
THOSE COMMENTS. I THINK A LOT OF
US HAVE PERSONAL EXPERIENCE AND
SOME STORIES NOT, YOU KNOW, NOT
JUST WHEN IT RELATES TO DEMENTIA
AND ALZHEIMER'S, BUT ALSO FOR
THE WORK WE DO. AND SO THIS IS
ONE OF THEM. CERTAINLY I LOST A
LOVED ONE WHO I ACTUALLY CARED
FOR AND KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE IN
THE FINAL MOMENTS AND DAYS. AND
WHEN YOU HAVE TO START SHARING A
ROOM, WHEN YOU HAVE TO START
SHARING A BED AND PUTTING, YOU
KNOW, MATS ON THE FLOOR TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY DON'T LEAVE. AND
YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW, YOU'RE
WARNED, THE LIST GOES ON. SO
THIS IS A VERY NEAR AND DEAR,
ISSUE TO ME. AND I CONTINUE TO
BE COMMITTED TO IT, BUT I'M SO
THANKFUL TO THE SUPPORTERS AND
TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR THE SUPPORT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR EGGMAN.
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL?
MOTION? IS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN
ASHBY? AYE. ASHBY. AYE. WHEN?
ARCHULETA. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE.
BECKER. DODD. AYE DODD. AYE.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER.
MENJIVAR. AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE
NILO. ROTH. ROTH AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. WILK. AYE WILK AYE. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. MOTION PASSES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU,
YOU NEED TO GO TO. WE'RE
ADJOURNED. SO I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING ELSE.